gym oh yeah
callum from south africa versus big
daddy mike from mozambique this is our
grand finals it's gonna be a race to
three however if callum wants to win the
entire tournament he has to win two sets
but first things first let's see what
happens this opening set as we start
things off
boom relax no
punish
yeah maybe too relaxed maybe too relaxed
there i like it the back ones they're
doing work
they're forcing a reaction here out of
calamity
it seems well it seems like he's jabbing
that's the thing that he's doing to kind
of get out of that
i like what i'm seeing here
yeah that was instant adaptation he's
been watching right he's taking notes oh
that sucks goes to the throw
he still has good positioning though
let's see what big daddy mike's able to
do here
there's a life slight life deficit
between the two but nothing too
worrisome but this is big it's not gonna
kill sidewall messes things up
[Music]
and that's actually one of the the
stories from the first episode right
there was a lot of hatchet kicks
a lot of hatch kicks that got hit uh if
callum had been blocking the lots of
those that would have been a very
different set yeah this time the
immediate block and lot's huge yeah he
might have been the one waiting in grand
finals had it been different either way
we're going right into this he's gonna
push him towards the wall let's see what
the wall combo is this time
he wants the time oh yeah he really
wants it man he really wants to be the
crowd pleaser
all brian players do right
yeah i mean even if they can't do it
they'll go for it hell yeah this is like
there was that one random tournament
that you played in and you ended up
getting brian and you did it
it was great
orbital over the drive let's go
fight yeah that's kind of crazy
boom nothing
yeah i mean look at this exchange nice
gets to follow oh i thought he did it
that was sick he you could tell he
tested him there he that down back too
is not guaranteed after taunt so he
tested them by my ducking
four
northern cross crosses dude
that move such a sick that's such a sick
move it is
oh here we go
gets the follow up what's the side step
attack no goes for the down 34
[Music]
to the flow
see what he does here no duck on the
second it doesn't matter locked and
loaded not going to get the wall but
it's going to do decent damage let's see
what the mix-up is soccer kick and
hatchet we're going to follow another
one there's the launch though he might
be dead he might be dead
not so
big daddy mike the clutch factor bro
that has been the tail dude the clutch
factor end of the round situation big
daddy mike has had it all day long he's
doing something that no brian player
does he lands the rage drive it's so
crazy he's like two already today that's
a a lifetime record here we have a new
season high that's crazy
i'm kidding by the way guys i'm kidding
by the way i'm just saying yeah hit the
rage drive
hit it i mean i guess it's a little bit
easier when they can't sidestep it right
yeah i mean this is timing on it right
in general like so many moments he's
found those openings uh and the clutch
block afterward right like i was like
low he he's like yes love blocking no
problem uh got the follow-up afterward
too
just crazy stuff and you know this is
what we expect from these two it's
always down the wire you can't really
predict what's gonna happen uh the big
difference in this set so far compared
to the first set callum is blocking the
hatchets and getting the full launchers
on them right yeah he's getting punished
even when he blocked it he wouldn't get
the launcher correctly i think he only
landed one correct punch on it in the
first set but this set already at least
three right but still didn't get in the
first game
in advocation of the devil i will play
devil's advocate here
maybe he wants him to block the low
maybe he wants to set him up for some
nasty stuff because brian has some
pretty devastating mids as well
but i feel like that's one way to do it
is if you can kind of train your enemy
to start
seeing those that are see not well you
can't really see it but starting to
block the the hatchet kicks right then
it kind of opens opens things up at
least a little bit more midwives maybe
we're gonna start seeing like sway into
orbital soccer kick a lot of others
yeah i mean that's like some next level
stuff right
but i mean again it all matters with uh
how you kind of do it because like
getting your low and blocked and kind of
launch punish is not the end of the
world it just means that hey they're
looking out for it now and sometimes
that's what you want that's that's what
you want because that means if they're
waiting for the low that means they're
not attacking that means they're waiting
true but i also feel like he's very
heavy on hatchet throughout like all the
opponents he's played against oh yeah oh
yeah for sure
right so i think it's just what he wants
like obviously he can mix it up uh i
want to see that i want to see where
layer two and where layer three is let
me let me see that i think i think we're
gonna see it by the end of the set
because right now there's been a lot of
good blocks on it a lot of big damage
out of it the problem is he still lost
the game right like despite getting all
those blocks and full launches on the
hatchets he still lost that first game
so that's got to be a little bit
demoralizing i think because i did feel
like that was one of the big differences
in that first set that was so close
between them yeah
definitely definitely but again we this
is just the beginning it was only the
first game we have potentially two sets
here let's see let's see of course if
callum is able to kind of fight back
which he did in in the past you know
so he could go evk
yeah i mean i mean he's he's been
stretching it out quite a bit for all of
the matches that we've seen him play
actually now that you mention it so
ability to fight and the ability to
adjust that's that's really what it
comes down to especially in short sets
and of course a little bit longer but
we'll see how this plays out of course
but not the you know going into this you
know without really knowing too much
about the players uh in south africa did
not expect to see
uh eddie and brian uh here i i was
thinking like we'd see some bob we'd see
some lars which we did see a lot of lars
by the way
bob dude
bob is like
bob's crazy now i
i don't see enough bob i feel like there
should be more bob out there
bob is crazy
anyways we're gonna go back into the
matchup it's precipice of fate
and it's callum again
sticking to eddie
uh and he's great with this character
right uh oh yeah see if we put them
together here though
every time i see this intro and i see
the tree move i'm like does that tree
really move yeah
i don't know it does it does in this in
this this uh fly over here
it is moving man can you brian brian and
eddie can you guys get out of the way
i'm trying to look at the background let
me see these trees man change
chains chains chains are you serious i
mean that was one of the weaknesses we
noticed right no throw breaks from calum
not as many
yeah
and that's the thing brian only has
uh other than normal throws he only has
one plus two throw brakes
for that thing if somebody's not
breaking through then you can just start
getting away with the regular throw too
oh yeah
like that is the mix of the throw game
now in tekken 7 people can't break those
inside the oneplus 2 or not
yeah inside the unfortunate thing is
some some characters don't really have
that right yep poor akuma doesn't have a
throat or a kuma
poor no one ever
you he needs buffs bro yeah
give him a throw and oh he's poor
yeah poor man said no one ever yeah
all right let's see what he does here
man he's uh he's waiting i don't know
what he's waiting for but he's waiting
for something big
different
way too far
town chilling back dashing all day i
like this approach though i mean
calum
and big daddy mike it's like they're
waiting they're they're building up
meter internal meter
waiting to explode yep damn explosion
it's called spirit
here we go
that way they can just let loose again
throws bro throws it's something that
we've seen already that those throws
have been working so much
drive
how did he land it
man nicely done calum the powers
yep
sometimes you just need that fighting
spirit
uh-huh there's the low the follow-up
what's gonna do again yo oh my gosh you
got impatient
yo things are getting different here for
calum i like it he tried to hit him with
that hot plate special to follow up here
let's see what he does
oh there you go and that's again how you
do it that's how you put the reaction
on reaction he's blocking him i believe
it round four
well he might get uh hit by soccer kick
on reaction next we'll see
because that's also on reaction
sometimes you get hit by by [ __ ] so hard
in the game you like reel backwards and
then you hit your head on the back of
your chair that's real that thing is
real that happens to you good luck all
the blessings sent your way
to catch him but he transitioned into
the fourth equals four here we go that's
an opportunity that down back to it was
close enough this should be the wall not
with that combo no sir taught too far as
well
i mean i feel like if he gets a taunt
jet upper i'm gonna give him the
tournament yep straight up we'll just
stop things right there more back two
three
oh all right keeps them there
not dead taunt
fakie heel flip for the win
let's get it big daddy mike
trying to go up 2-0 here
he's fishing
see what he does
dude these guys are playing so compact
yet going crazy at the same time i agree
he'll punier
the wall
he's the late tech there
like what i'm seeing man you really
punch barry you know punch perry eddie
gordo like that is it that serious
that's the one he needed he's mine mind
boggled up boggled
boots
oh my gosh unfortunate
hey big daddy is one match away from
winning the entire tournament rip
yeah he is uh and that that wall balance
was so crucial right like the angle
looked good where he was away from the
wall off it a little bit it wasn't like
right there at the wall so that was just
a huge drop huge i like i like what
we're seeing here this brian fury
a big daddy is redeeming the big daddy
name after it's been soiled in the past
he's bringing it back
yeah you forgot about him i never forgot
i don't forgot like what's wrong with
diesel big daddy cool was one of the
choo choo
no thank you everyone for watching on
the official channels i appreciate it
and the official youtube anyways we're
going to go into what could be the final
match of the tournament i'm excited for
it
definitely and you know when you really
look back at the last round of that
final game those two back-to-back huge
mistakes from callum right he blocked
the hatchet and went for while standing
too he didn't even do the wild standing
one four like he's been doing right i
mean he had that opportunity and he's
just like dude that was like the one
time in this set that he really failed
to punish it and then immediately after
that lands the wall bounce
and doesn't really follow up with the
screw attack or combo you know so
maybe it was just unexpected because i
mean how often does that land for eddie
because you know it's one of the it's
one of the slowest and why did you do it
hit it you know
i don't know man let's ask him
it's just unfortunate but here we go 2-0
lead for big
mike
needs one more
he fell into his trap this is what he
wanted the whole time you think so he be
infinite or sure do you want it you
remember once he picks him finisher he
gets that crazy power off
he gets that crazy power up
let's see what he does anyways this
good callum every time he lost he didn't
pick it last night because obviously we
had walls right but this time he did
pick it he was saving up that spirit we
were talking about all right oh my gosh
he's locked breaker through his spirit
he's dead he's broken
the spurs running low
he's running low
got a refill
uh-huh
add some fuel to the fire
what it's an electric car oh my god
we're dead
pixels
all right big daddy feeling obviously
hey yo mikey
let's go cal never given up
i'm never gonna get tired of seeing that
seeing that downforce equals four launch
is so cool
[Music]
oh really you're gonna go for that big
dropkick there
[Music]
well
oh he's gonna have to be careful
okay
[Music]
he does have the life lead so calum
let's see how he kind of deals
he will punish the orbital that's easier
said than done
easier said than done
very very nicely done there callum all
right
round count tied game three
calum definitely
focused in you know he's got that game
william going on right now
in the chair leaning forward front half
of the seat face closer to the monitor
[Music]
oh there's the hatchet this is how it
starts those hats oh this could be big
oh
the falls i just got quiet afterwards
like where's the jedi
oh man
life is pretty close here
good jab keep out
he's testing him
ended with the high version
oh
he's in rage
how's he gonna deal with it
you can't relax
against the galaxy the orbital is too
strong
here we go daddy mike
tournament point
mirage is good
calum not out of it yet
[Music]
good combo lots of life there
you know those hatchets are coming out
he's gonna chop away
you're gonna hit him with that chief
thunder
see what he does
good option
oh he jabbed it
uh-huh wow bottom nice down back too
that was smart yeah he wanted to get the
orbital there but here we go final round
still tournament point for big daddy
mike could close it out with the 3-0
here
trying to stay alive in the tournament
big chance here big opportunity right
now big daddy mike is he going to change
things up how is he going to approach
here calum right now going with the down
forward too he's going to have the life
lead is he going to run or he's going to
continue the pressure that's the
question pressure
pressure
to counter it
has been the answer
nice oh there's the launch he's going to
put him into range as well let's see
what he does with it last time oh yes
it's the running three low that is
something that we have not seen much out
of calum at all and you know i had
flashbacks at first that as soon as he
tapped into rage it was like three hits
and he was dead right two hits so i was
scared for a moment but callum staying
alive and will not be asleep oh yeah it
might be a reset after this that's how
when these days play i feel like that's
you only needed one man win one match
you get a reset that's crazy i don't
know it might be a reset guys i'm just
saying you know
anything could happen here but calum
definitely looked good there the
downpour two as soon as he hit the
counter down for two i was like this is
what's been missing in this set so far
right uh so and then he immediately
followed the instant running three uh
these are options he hasn't really gone
to in this set so really nice to see
callum bringing out everything uh
because you need to right it's it's
grand finals you know you go home he he
finally got the call the wake-up call
right this is what he needed and again
hopefully it's it's that you know a
little boost that he needs to really get
back into the match because again it's
nowhere close to being over he needs to
win two more matches still
right he needs to win two more matches
and my thoughts here is you know as you
go into this big daddy mike has the
option to pick the stage right
he's probably gonna go for something
that can restrict eddie's movement i
wouldn't be surprised if we saw like a
suit or a human dojo out of them right
the walls obviously will benefit will
benefit him overall but anyways either
way we're going to find out as we go
into this matchup
what's going to happen because it's all
coming down to this he might be so
carefree oh he he picked the jimmy j
tran stage
oh he wants damage
best music there are two
two breakable walls here that could lead
to a ton of damage it actually really
benefits combo wise
um brian fury this is a really good
stage for him
anyways
get to the choppa
get to the choppa
here we go another potent final game and
you know
if your big daddy mike here and you you
knew how close it was to winning
sometimes that plays mind games on you
let's see if you can stay focused here
he's had the clutch factor end of rounds
usually
oh yeah
go ahead daddy
let's go oh here we go he's gonna push
towards the wall all right i would like
to go i would like to see him go for
down three two after blocking that
especially when he's near the wall
down down forward too and that was right
after big daddy mike did not punish
earlier too by the way
geez look at the combo trying to catch
him again
oh oh bad trade what no counter no
counter hit yo someone got robbed
how did that knock what the hell
i'm so confused
nice
call him call him and let him know
i'm continuing his his his momentum from
the last match getting another round
looking to tie things up here
uh-huh nice pickup there it is you try
to transition into something the
follow-up he has the wall
no tech rolls
damn that's the strats hey if he's gonna
stay on the floor he's not tech rolling
go for it
i love that option
orville's been killing him yep it's fine
not much damage
those back ones they're gonna add up but
he has to watch out those back ones even
though it does help him provide some
pressure he has to watch out for the jab
and the down forward too
spring
all right interesting interesting
tying it up on rounds here
that's it number four
best of five
important
he's still got it
don't you bro my god okay that was close
to these guys
oh my gosh that's guaranteed too that's
a that's a true combo
it's on down back one plus two here we
go orbital break them
break a breaker
to the wall and you're dead
tournament point big daddy mike
fight
can he do it we'll call him oh my gosh
that could have been a launch too
oh what are you gonna do
galaxy's favorite the orbital heel
here's your chance han
[Music]
it's okay
no perfect
yes
wall's in the way
oh sidewalks are messing up
oh
big daddy mike over callum
and big daddy mike is the tekken online
challenge 2021 south african region
champion congratulations big daddy mike
nice to meet you gotta give it up well
represented mozambique ends up winning
the south african regional tournament
the master event here and of course he
is going to be the big points leader now
here in the region pretty much guarantee
i want to say pretty much guaranteeing
him a spot in the regional finals for
sure great stuff nonetheless good stuff
yeah and grace left the calum as well
right very entertaining matches
throughout the day uh obviously his
first big danny mike was ridiculous
probably still my favorite set of the
day oh yeah another crazy run back in
the loser final as well so great stuff
to count throughout the entire day let's
take a look-see here